the future of the Terminator franchise
has been in flux since 2009 and now
Arnold Schwarzenegger has some brutal
insights on what went wrong 1984 said
Terminator is one of the most
influential science fiction films of all
time and its sequel Terminator 2
Judgment Day is often heralded as one of
the best sci-fi movies ever made not
only were those movies incredibly well
received but they also solidified Arnold
Schwarzenegger's status as a movie
Superstar he had appeared in films
before then but portraying the T800 took
his star to another level
I'll be back
he did indeed come back Schwarzenegger
has continued to be part of the
franchise even in his most recent
installments however none of the other
four films in The Terminator series have
lived up to the Majesty of those first
two in the eyes of fans and critics and
while Schwarzenegger seems to believe
the franchise will live on somehow his
time in it is done especially after the
reception to the previous two there
hasn't been any word on another movie in
The Terminator franchise since 2019's
dark fate that film wasn't received well
by critics and only grows 261 million
dollars at the global box office which
is a fairly poor performance for such a
recognizable series it definitely
requires some retooling and the topic of
Terminator came up on Arnold
Schwarzenegger spoke at The Hollywood
Reporter about his career at large when
NASA the franchise was done the actor
sounded pretty adamant saying the
franchise is not done I'm done I got the
message loud and clear that the world
wants to move on with a different theme
when it comes to the Terminator here
means that he'll always have fond
memories of the franchise because this
one really jump started his acting
career but it sounds like if there's
another Terminator movie he won't be
part of it and most of that is due to
the reception of the last two films he
admitted the first three movies were
great number four I was not in because I
was governor then five and six that
enclosed the deal as far as I'm
concerned we knew that ahead of time
because they were just not well written
you and I were built for the same
purpose
and Legions the only future I came from
a future like that
it failed it sounds like Schwarzenegger
and crew knew for a while Genesis and
Doug Fates weren't going to be smash
successes and the response to those
movies likely dampened any enthusiasm he
had about continuing the role but to
rest assured Terminator will continue
just as soon as anyone can figure out
what to do with it when it comes to
franchises as big as Terminator the
question of the next installment always
seems like a matter of when and not if
we'll likely get Terminator 7 at some
point but the series needs some
renovations to stay up and running
especially if Schwarzenegger is Calling
it Quits the next movie is going to need
another hook to bring in audiences which
didn't exactly work out for Terminator
Salvation when the actor was busy being
governor of California recently James
Cameron who directed the first two
Terminator installments spoke about
potentially returning to the series
while nothing set in stone the filmmaker
declared on the smartless podcasts that
there have been discussions but he also
suggested he might change the direction
of the franchise I would make it much
more about about the AI side of but then
then kind of bad robots Gone Gone Crazy
granted Cameron has his hands full with
Avatar sequels these days so it's
unlikely he could fit to Terminator
movie in there too but he could be on
board as a producer and help guide a new
vision possibly one that emphasizes the
existential threat of artificial
intelligence over another T800 reskin
whatever the direction of the franchise
holds Schwarzenegger made his thoughts
loud and clear the Terminator will live
on but he won't be there
I won't be back
[Music]